Turkey's president is defending his
country's invasion of northern Syria in
a Wall Street Journal op-ed president
air Dewan says the operation aims to
address the refugee crisis saying quote
the international community should
either join our efforts or begin
admitting refugees Charlie d'Agata is in
to hook Iraq near the border with Syria
president air21 has actually doubled
down on the offensive saying that his
forces are going to see this through to
the end despite growing international
pressure to bring the fighting to an end
it may be hard to hear president Trump's
demands for a ceasefire over the
deafening overnight explosions on the
battlefields of northern Syria if
anything turkeys stepped up its military
campaign in a land grab as Syrian regime
forces race to retake key Kurdish cities
the US military is now largely out of
the picture retreating US troops have
been seen on the move to avoid being
caught between two advancing armies a
Russian journalist posted video
allegedly showing the abandoned US base
in manbij saying I'm now at the American
base let's see how they're living
America's quick exit changed the
landscape of Northeast Syria
dramatically and immediately we not only
had to avoid Syrian regime forces but
the Turkish military it's extremist
militias and an emerging Isis threat
caught up in the widening chaos Kurdish
civilians victims of indiscriminate
shelling packed into overstretched
hospitals we've witnessed how
under-resourced these facilities are one
surgeon told us they're desperate for
medicine and equipment and on the verge
of collapse UN estimates of people
displaced by the fighting keeps climbing
it's now a hundred sixty thousand
defending the offensive in the wall
street journal' turkish President
Erdogan said his country had reached its
limit dealing with 3.6 million refugees
from the Syrian conflict Turkey also
views Syrian Kurdish fighters as
terrorists that must be eradicated
forces who were once America's most
loyal ally in the
fight against Isis we've been in touch
with Kurdish commanders this morning who
tell us that the US military in kobani
have actually asked for their protection
to keep Syrian regime forces out of that
area so they're able to draw safely
thank you Charlie d'Agata the picture is
very difficult to watch thank you